if I can get five minutes to a chick and
that's worth two weeks of some other
dude's time but that's reality so where
you are on the scale is just basically
how much of your time you have to give
now you can still give all your time to
a woman treat her like a queen be
respected by your peers she can be happy
with you I'm not saying she will be any
in fact I'll argue she'll be happier
with that man than she'll be with a
[__] guy like me I'm not even out
here someone make chicks happy I'm not
even saying that I'm saying that she'll
get the amount of time that she's gonna
want from that man the amount of
attention is linked to his status but at
a true high level status of man it's two
DMS 10 seconds 10 seconds 10 seconds
stop that's kind of